you're watching al jazeera we're taking
you to qatar's hamad airport airport
where the qatar airways plane has just
landed at the airport after departing
kabul with around 158 passengers it's
the second flight from kabul to doha u.s
german canadian french dutch british
belgian and mauritanian citizens are
said to have been on board
currently speaking his doctor most
muslig
he's qatar's special envoy for the
minister of foreign affairs for
counter-terrorism and mediation in
conflict resolution
he's been on the flight with those uh
citizens qatari and turkish teams have
been working at kabul's airport to
resume their civilian flights let's
listen into what he's saying fully
scheduled
with respect to the air navigation
technically speaking the airport is
operational
however
there are certain considerations that
must be taken
and
at the same time
each and every airliner
should do their own calculations simply
there are certain technical
considerations in addition to other
commercial
matters to be taken into account at the
same time the undertake
the caretaker government of afghanistan
is doing all what they can to streamline
the operation of the airport and as you
can see qatar airways is
uh landing and taking off from the
airport
we have done our best
to have these flights
taken off and landing at kabul airport
is quite operational and this is what's
the most important now
we found
the
caretaker government is quite
cooperative in facilitating actually the
the travel of the passengers with no
barriers with no restrictions
and also uh
their collaboration with us to uh
reopen the airport a few works to be
done and mostly administrative
and i think as far as the the the as far
as the airport is concerned as i said
it's operational it's up to the
international airlines to uh
to uh to uh to fly to kabul or not and
also there are more administrative works
that the caretaker government
should take
uh in order to make it
more more more
operational we have been working with
our partners especially turkey
to make it uh to expedite the process of
making it even
more efficient and this has something to
do with
you know with further talks with the
caretaker government to see what's the
best way to make this effort more
efficient
do you expect that there's going to be
flights daily now from kabul to qatar
and also there was a little bit of
confusion yesterday about whether these
were charter flights or commercial
flights or passenger flights could you
just elaborate on that a bit as far as
what exactly the statuses of these
planes that are coming in well i think
the most important this is not
evacuated
uh mission this is a
three passage three movement passengers
uh traveling through uh international
airport to international airport i think
it's not it's not important to me i
would say to call it charter or
commercial the bottom line is that the
airport is operational people can travel
easily uh and that's the most important
i guess it's up to
other airlines to fly to kabul or not
it's i think as far as the civil
aviation is concerned i think it's fully
operational and do you think there's
gonna be more of these flights each day
now well i think this is uh beyond my uh
uh beyond my uh uh control this is up to
qatar airways
and it's up to the caretaker governments
to engage with qatar airways
to engage and ask for more flights and i
think this is just up to to the airline
and to to the caretaker government
airport
as i mentioned earlier
the
cabin airport is fit for navigation it
is fit
for
receiving and dispatching
commercial flights
and as you can see qatar airways is
flying on daily basis from the airport
at however
it is up to other airliners
to schedule their own flights according
to their respective needs
we are doing all what we can with our
international partners
to speed up the full operation of the
airport
and we
hope that other airline companies will
be able to fly freely
and on
routine basis to and from the airport
that is uh doctor mortal i've been
marching
that's qatar's special envoy of the
minister of foreign affairs for
counter-terrorism and mediation in
conflict of resolution talking on the
apron of
doha's hamad airport
just after a qatar airways plane landed
at the airport after departing kabul
with around 158 passengers it's
estimated it's said to be the second
flight from kabul to doha on board
where citizens from the u.s they were
german canadian french dutch british
belgian and mauritanian we see pictures
there of them a variety of different
people including children as you can see
there are some families coming down
the gangway there let's talk to our
correspondent mohammad jam joom who has
been live as the plane has landed
muhammad um dr mukhlai bring majeda
khatani there making a very specific
point that this was not an evacuation
mission this was free passage of
passengers from international airport to
international airport it seems that the
qatar is very keen to stress that kabul
airport after its intervention and that
of turkey is now open for business
well that's right and and one of the
things that i asked dr
about is whether or not this was
considered by fatality officials to be a
charter flight there was a little a bit
of confusion yesterday as to whether the
first flight that took off from from
kabul and landed here in doha that one
had about 113 passengers on board if
that was just a regular passenger flight
or if that was considered a charter
flight and it was clarified today by a
futuri official even before this flight
landed that this is technically a
charter flight when i asked dr okafani
about that he stressed the fact that
look these are passengers that are able
to leave of their own volition yesterday
before the flight took off from kabul on
kabul airport uh hamid karzai airport in
kabul he had said that these are
passengers who have their papers uh who
have tickets and boarding passes and
they got on this flight whether or not
they are technically considered evacuees
the fact of the matter is they were able
to leave and that's what the officials
were here tonight are stressing dr
saying for him at the moment the
important thing is that the passengers
had their papers that they were able to
get on those planes and that they were
able to arrive here i attacked
as well about whether or not we should
expect more of these types of flights in
the days to come specifically
airways flights like the plane you see
behind me coming from kabul arriving
here in doha and he said that that's
going to be up to in some regards of
other airways they're going to be you
know corresponding communicating with
the airport in kabul and arranging these
flights so
there's still a little bit of vagueness
about how exactly this proceeds but one
of the things that he stressed in these
remarks from the tarmac here in doha
was that
the airport in kabul is almost fully
operational now that flights uh can get
there that they can take off from there
and that uh with the thought that it is
working with the turks they have been
able to get the airport in kabul into a
semi-workable order and they're happy
about that now i should mention also the
fact that of these around 158 passengers
who arrived here this evening they are
going to be processed they're going to
be taken through customs through
passport control and then uh they are
going to be taken to a compound here in
doha which has been housing temporarily
many of those who are in transit some of
them are
refugees some of them are evacuees
until they get to their final
destination there are hundreds of those
afghans who have been at that compound
for a few weeks now
when we saw
the passengers de-plane
you certainly felt a palpable sense of
relief there were many families there
were parents and there were children
and you could tell that they were really
glad to have finally been able to leave
kabul and to finally get here although i
must add there still is a lot of
uncertainty for their future they are
going to be here at least for tonight
but where they go and when they go from
here that's not exactly clear at this
stage and of course that is going to be
concerning because one would imagine
that there are going to be families and
friends who are waiting for passengers
off that plane uh to to get in touch
with them and so on i know you were
there when the first plane out of kabul
to doha
landed um yesterday on thursday um just
give us a sense of what it was like then
given the fact that uh
given us the fact that that was the
first flight out of kabul
rob i'm so sorry to have to interrupt
you but uh airport security is telling
us we're going to have to leave so i'm
going to have to make my my answer here
quite brief
last night when we were here when we saw
the first passengers arrive i can tell
you that they were extremely relieved
there was one canadian woman who told us
that she couldn't even sleep on the
flight as exhausted as she was as as
harrowing a journey as it had been for
her to even get on that plane she
couldn't sleep because she was she was
so nervous about what was going to
happen next but she was so relieved to
have been able to leave afghanistan my
apologies we are going to have to um we
are going to have to decamp from here
thank you mohammed i understand jim jude
thank you very much indeed that's
muhammad jam jim talking to us from
hamad airport we're just seeing some
pictures uh the latest pictures of those
some of those passengers coming off that
second qatari flight
from qatar airways landed at qatar's
hamad airport
probably about 15 minutes or so ago it's
the second flight to come out of kabul
airport on board as i mentioned before
there have been citizens from the united
states germany canada
dutch french belgian british and
mauritanian we understand that it may
well be that more will be coming out but
the we heard dr muklak bin merced
special envoy of the minister of foreign
affairs for counterterrorism and
mediation in conflict resolution he was
speaking uh to our correspondent
mohammed jam jhoom just a short while
ago and he had also been at plain pins
to say that this was not a vacuum
evacuation mission this was free passage
of passengers from and the international
airport at kaupul to another
international airport he said it was up
to other carriers to decide whether or
not they could take flights into kabul